[Music]
every summer has a soundtrack that
brings those memories just rushing back
i can't wait to hear what this summer's
biggest hits are going to be now this
next artist just might have the sound of
the summer hey guys i love you so i
recorded that when he was like four and
a half he's like eight
i wrote this song like three years ago
and i didn't want to put on the collab
album because i wanted to do it by
myself and i wanted to close the record
another feature on jimmy's new album the
one and only jennifer lopez
[Music]
i have a friend of mine that works with
her
and he reached out and said hey we want
to do a remix of her song on my way
would you be down i was like of course
i'd be down bro we got questions
[Music]
sherry had her part recorded
i recorded my part in nashville the next
day and sent it back
if she hadn't approved it it wouldn't
have happened
let alone been on my record it's just
great to do songs that people have been
fans of for a long time
[Music]
pretty sure you're loving every minute
and you're going on tour again with
carrie underwood are you kidding me in
october yeah that'll be fine yeah
gentleman rhinestone store
and how much do you wear i have a lot
maybe too much
maybe too much but there's no such thing
as too much
[Music]
brought to you by the dq summer blizzard
menu featuring new caramel drumstick
with peanuts dq happy tastes good